[Applause]
[Music]
it was reported that 20
000 scotland fans traveled to london for
the england scotland game
almost two weeks ago
if that number is correct more than one
in 20
took the coronavirus with them across
scotland
32 539 cases were reported between june
the 11th
and 28th nearly 2 000 of them are known
to have attended one or more
euro 2020 events while they were
infectious
almost two-thirds of them reported
traveling to london
either going to wembley or watching in a
fan zone
or pub let's not let everybody else off
the hook
that isn't a football fan there's been
32 000 positives in scotland since the
euros began
many of them may be connected to house
parties and groups and people meeting
to watch the football but some won't be
this virus doesn't care what you're
watching
it doesn't care what you're doing it
cares that you're together the
statistics
show 13 of the 3 000 scottish ticket
holders at wembley
almost 400 people had the virus despite
all having returned negative lateral
flow tests
glasgow's hampton park stadium is also
singled out in the statistics
for each of the two scotland matches
played at hampton park roughly 12 000
people
attended the stadium what these figures
tell us is that one in three hundred
there or thereabouts
subsequently tested positive for
coronavirus
what we don't know is how many people
they
infected i think what is problematic is
that in a perfect world
with numbers skyrocketing policymakers
who said okay we'll just press pause and
we're not going ahead with these events
but the money the sponsorship the
planning the players the fans
really difficult call so they went ahead
the scottish government had encouraged
fans without tickets
not to travel to london health officials
are now working to trace
close contacts of those known to have
been infected as the risk
from mass events continues to be
evaluated
gerar tub sky news edinburgh